so there was a period early last week
where we had some new twenty twenty
democratic or democratic primary polls
and Pete Budaj edge was up quite a bit
as high as nearly twelve percent and we
were wondering is this going to stick or
is it temporary did Pete Buddha judge
peek last week we also saw last week in
those early early last week polls that
Bernie Sanders was down at about the
same time all the way down to about 15
percent nationally which was Bernie's
lowest in months and we were wondering
is this going to stick is this for real
and then we had no new polls for about a
week we now have two new ones and they
appear to be on the same page and that
page is one that says that mayor Pete's
pop too close to 12 percent nationally
was temporary he's backed down several
points to an average of nine polling
eight and nine in the last two polls
from Monmouth and Politico morning
consult meanwhile Bernie Sanders and to
a lesser extent Elizabeth Warren have
recovered some of their losses Bernie
climbed from 15 to about 17 over the
last week but the last two polls
actually have Bernie at 21 and 22
respectively putting him in second place
nationally ahead of Elizabeth Warren
Warren also gaining a little bit in her
recent average polling in third place in
both new polls and meanwhile Joe Biden
continues to fluctuate between 26 and 30
polling 26 in the Monmouth poll and 30
in the politico morning consult poll now
these are national numbers and they are
not hugely surprising mayor Pete's pop
seemed sort of isolated it didn't seem
likely to sustain now with Kamala Harris
removed we are seeing where her three
percentage points are sort of being
distributed but it's almost mid to
semper which means we have to be looking
more and more of those first caucuses
and primaries which are Iowa and New
Hampshire followed by Nevada and South
Carolina so let's do that and only in
sum do we have recent polling in Iowa
Budaj edge was way up last month but
there's a new poll out today which has
him back down to third place no longer
leading that's not surprising
he's down nationally it makes sense he
might be down in Iowa as well Biden and
Bernie are fighting for first
place in Iowa in New Hampshire we also
have a new poll out today Budaj edge has
dropped from 22 to 18 makes sense but
still technically in first place 18 to
17 over Biden but certainly within the
margin of error in Nevada we don't have
polling since the first half of November
at that point Biden was well ahead of
both Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders
who were roughly tied for second place
but we need new polling there and then
in South Carolina again no new polling
since November 17th Biden was well ahead
there with Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
fighting for second place but a
relatively distant second so right now
we really need some new state polling in
some of these early states were only
about a month and a half from the first
votes in Iowa Pete Budaj edge is no
longer ahead there were about two and a
half months from our first votes in New
Hampshire a mayor Pete has dropped there
and is tied for first place rather than
leading and meanwhile we've lost Kamala
Harris she's ended her campaign Tulsi
Gabbard is polling 1% she's actually
polling 0% in two recent polls she's
decided to skip the debate later this
month we'll talk about that a little bit
later
she hasn't qualified for that debate
anyway but she's skipping it regardless
and we are going to follow the polling
we'll hopefully have some new early
State polling for you early next week
and more national polls as we did have a
lull there of almost 7 to 10 days or so
and the race has continued to adjust so
now that we've gotten polling out of the
way let's talk about the sixth
democratic debate coming up next week